it's always a good time to talk about
fall prevention for older adults
especially as we prepare our homes for
the holidays we stop by Intermountain
Healthcare the sponsors of this segment
to learn more
hi my name is Dr Giddish delotte and I
work for Intermountain Healthcare we're
at the South Decatur office in Las Vegas
and today we're going to talk a little
bit about Falls and fall prevention
fault is a big part of the health care
cost every 13 seconds a elderly patient
ends up in an emergency room due to fall
and one in four Americans has a major
fall that requires hospitalization and
every 20 minutes an adult dies from a
fall as we know in adults hip fractures
are a big cause of morbidity and require
prolonged hospitalization and
Rehabilitation and a lot of these
patients never really get back to their
previous quality of life and this is
what we can do this is all preventable
potentially and this is what we're going
to talk about going forward so exercise
is a big part of safety and preventing
Falls and really strengthening your core
is really important part of that and
that's where exercise can really help
and keeping your home safe making sure
you don't have any rugs that you can
trip over making sure the floors are not
slippery those are some really important
things as well talk to your family your
family can really be a good asset in
helping you assess your home safety and
then of course ask your physician what
your risk of falling is and perhaps he
or she can give you some advice as we
know in elderly patients medications is
a big part of of their cognition and
fall risk so review the medications with
your pharmacist and your physician on a
regular basis take extra precautions and
unfamiliar environments especially when
you're traveling next we suggest you get
your vision and hearing check on an
annual basis and it's really important
that you have uniform Lighting in your
house and if you have steps in the house
make sure you pay contrasting colors so
to really give a good sense of depth
when you're walking around your house
and finally of course when you are
sitting for a long period of time or
laying down make sure you take your time
when you get up and if you do stand
stand for a few seconds because with a
lot of medications elderly patients are
on they can certainly get lightheaded
and that could be very very common way
of falling where we are is a My
Generation Clinic and basically it's a
concierge service for seniors and we
have 30 locations around the valley and
we are accepting new patients and this
is the enrollment period so please
assess your needs and think about
Intermountain Healthcare
thank you to Intermountain Healthcare
for sponsoring this segment you can head
to
intermountainhealthcare.org Nevada for
more information we'll be right back